[Music]
I have my crown rather a spelling done
and then my whistle with all my buttons
on like Jaws
but
I bet the old rolls don't know how to do
this
we had to move away because the rent we
couldn't pay the moving van came round
just after dark
oh well you can't trust especially was
like the old-time coppers when you can't
find your way and get off me Para
I'm dying Gould I'm the Pearly queen of
Saint pancreas part of the Pearly Royals
my Royal duty is a pearly Queen
um is to go and raise fun and funds for
Charities the Pearly Royals date right
back to Victorian times among London's
fruit and vegetable sellers known as
Costas and the local orphan and rat
catcher called Henry Croft
Legend has it he stumbled across a
Shipwrecked Crate by the Thames filled
with sixty thousand Pearl buttons he
sewed them all onto an old suit and used
it to raise money for his orphanage the
suit was such a success that he got his
cost of friends involved too appointing
a pearly king and queen to all 28 London
boroughs to raise money for local
charities
titles are handed down through Families
my great-granddad was George Dahl the
first belly king of Saint Pancras and
led 17 saucepan Lids my granddad Alf
became the Pearly Prince and then my dad
Alf named after his dad was a pearly
king of Saint Pancras I became the
Pearly queen of Saint Pancras and my
sons Terry Lee and Simon are the Pearly
king and a couple of princes and my
grandchildren are the Pearly Prince and
princesses of some pancreas
does that make sense
we like to support royalty like
Jubilee's coronations and that's what
we've bumped into them over the years a
few pearly's got invited to a
celebration and the queen came along and
she looked at us like that I gave her
the thumbs up and the old the old Queen
Mum
she was a girl
as in any families you get the ups and
downs so the royal family aren't any
different all I can say to Charlie our
lovely King Charles is just stay
grounded and listen to your heart you
jam top
laughs
[Music]
this is one of dad's pearly suits it was
the main one that you like to wear oh
you got the ship on the back she was in
The Merchant Navy and a crown my son
Terry was in the RAF hang on let's let's
go to the hats okay so that's one I just
got off eBay like come off an original
pelly Queens um so it's my friend's
Jimmy's who has different styles of
pearly hats her Couture isn't it
millinery that's the word the whistle
I'm sitting in the whistling flu I'm
sitting in here's the one that I that I
sewed uh started 40 years ago and just
added bits and took bits off I've got
fish on my suit we used to eat fish and
jelly deals lovely jubbly right
horseshoe for luck I've also got a
symbol of Great Ormond Street on my on
my skirt the symbol of the charity that
we represent where we do knees up so or
we're going out and about buttons get
lost so you're always sewing on more
buns then I might think oh I wanna I
wanna put a different symbol on there
basically it's an ongoing piece of work
Diane now lives in East Sussex but she
regularly makes Royal visits to her
Realm
London the old oak smoke to be able to
walk along the streets is quite
privileged when people come up it's just
holding their hand it's very deep and
meaningful because some people look at
look at me and go well what's this all
about and I just say it's about love I
might not know you but I'll get to know
you and to me pearly symbolize that
connection with each other
foreign
motto is one never knows it's very
meaningful because in life as we're all
aware one never knows I get quite
emotional about this because
through life's ups and downs you need
good friends and family in between and
that's what counts it's sharing the good
times as well coming together
socializing having a good vibe nothing
better than to go to the battle Cruise
or a pixia and a good old Jolly up and
knees up and sing song
up the apples and pears and through the
Oreo more into seeing me dear I'll
travel in strife
a pint of pigs for supper then off to
Uncle Ned Oh What A Wonderful Life I
have
I'm sorry
[Laughter]